تحياتي لكم اعزائي المشاهدين هذه ساعه
اخباريه نخصص معظمها لتغطيه التطورات في
السودان البدايه بالعناوين
الدعم السريع يعلن تمديد الهدنه في
السودان لاثنتين ساعه وتجدد اتهامها للجيش
بقصف مواقعها
[تصفيق]
والوضع الامني في الخرطوم من سيء لاسوا
عمليات نهب في الخرطوم بحري وام درمان
نحو اليوم العاشر تمضي عمليات الاجلاء
لرعايه دول العربيه والاجنبيه والاسيويه
من شرق والعربيه في بورتسودان حيث مركز
الاجلاء الرئيسي عالقون يطالبون بالخروج
وفي اخبارنا الاخرى ايضا
اوكرانيا تناقض نفسها بشان الهجوم المضاد
يقول انه سيبدا حتى من دون المقاتلات
وجيشه يقول ان الامر مستحيل
[موسيقى]
اذا نستمر في المتابعه للوضع في السودان
وقبل انتهاء الهدنه الخامسه هناك تعلن
قوات الدعم السريع عن هدنه سادسه هذه
الهدنه كسابقاتها لمده 72 ساعه تبدا من
منتصف الليل لفتح الممرات الانسانيه
وتسهيل الوصول الى المناطق الامنه الى
الان لم يصدر الجيش رد فعل على تمديد
الهدنه هذا ولكن ايضا في الاعلانات
السابقه كان الجيش يؤكد موافقته في وقت
لاحق ورغم الهدن المعلنه الا ان الالتزام
الكامل بها يبقى منقوصا فعلى مدار الايام
الثلاثه الماضيه كانت الاشتباكات متفرقه
في الصالحه والحلفايه وجبرى والصحافه
فمثلا تم خلق الهدنه اليوم في منطقه السوق
الشعبي في ام درمان حيث تم رصد اصوات
الاشتباكات في المنطقه وفي مقابله مع
العربيه اتهم مستشار قائد قوات الدعم
السريع اتهمه الطائرات طائرات الجيش بقصف
مواقعهم رغم الهدنه
واعلنا التزامنا بهدنه
ايضا تضرب وتحوم حول مواقع الدعم السريع
ما يسمع من رصاص ومضادات الدعم السريعه
الارضيه تتصدى لهجوم طيران لكن على ارض
الواقع في ولايه الخرطوم في كل مدينه لكن
لا توجد قوات مشاهده للجيش او قوات تتحرك
من مكان الى مكان للجيش هذه مساله حسمت من
الايام لا يوجد تحرك للجيش داخل ولايه
الخرطوم
اكد العميد نبيل عبد الله المتحدث باسم
الجيش السوداني ان قوات الجيش تمكنت من
السيطره على سبع عشره ولايه وتفرض سيطرتها
بنسبه 80% في ولايتي الخرطوم وغربور التي
تشهد مواجهات قبليه يجري العمل على وقفها
السيطره كامله على كل الولايات 17
والسيطره
يعني بنسبه 80%
في ولايتي الخرطوم واما ولايه غرب
الفردفان غربي دارفور فهذه هي طبعا بها
متغير ومتغير الاخير الذي تمصل في اندلاع
الصراع القبلي والذي يعني الان يجري
احتواءه بواسطه السلطات المحليه هناك عن
طريق لجنه امن الولايه وهذا المسلحه يعني
تسيطر تماما على جميع مقراتها بما فيها
القياده العامه بما فيها بيت الضيافه وحتى
منطقه القصر الجمهوري حديثهم يعني
وتركيزهم على السيطره على العاصمه ليست
ليس ليس ليس صحيحا
قوات الاحتياطي المركزي السودانيه
هي قوه شرطيه تم انشاؤها عام 1990 وهي من
الادارات المهمه بقوات الشرطه وتقع
قيادتها بالكلاكله جنوب الخرطوم وتنتشر في
العاصمه والولايات تم تدريب عناصرها
للقيام بعمليات المسلحه وشاركت قبل اعوام
في عمليات قتاليه مع الجيش في ولايه
دارفور وجنوب كردفان والنيل الازرق وشرق
السودان سلاحها اقرب لسلاح الجيش وبها فرق
عمليات خاصه تتدرب على يد القوات الخاصه
بالقوات المسلحه بدات الانتشار يوم السبت
بجنوب الخرطوم على ان يتوالى نزولها
لمناطق اخرى من العاصمه هذه القوات خاضعه
لعقوبات امريكيه منذ مارس من عام 2022
بتهمه استخدام القوه المفرطه ضد محتجين في
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
ونبدا المتابعه من الخرطوم بحري معنا من
هناك صحفيه محمد اسحاق عثمان محمد اهلا بك
هذه الليله تنتهي الهدنه على
المفترض ان يتم تمديدها 73 ساعه اخرى ولكن
قبيل انتهاء هذه الهدنه كيف تصف الوضع
نعم مرحبا محمود قبل لحظات من الان انتهت
عمليه التمشيط التي كانت الان في هذه
المنطقه التي شهدناها قبل قليل كما ذكرت
تابع كل المواطنين وكانوا
موجودين بحوالي القوات المسلحه التي اقبلت
عمليه التنشيط في منطقه جسر الحلفايه
والدروشاب ومنطقه الكادرو حتى قبل لحظات
من الان المكان الذي انا
هذه البنايه من خلفي كانت قبل قليل ايضا
عمليات تمشيط كبيره جدا شملت هذه المنطقه
تم
من المنتمين لقوات الدعم السريع الذين
كانوا يتجولون
داخل منطقه
كوبري الحلفا يتم القبض على عدد من
المنتسبي قوات الدعم السريع عددهم تجاوز
العشره اشخاص
نعم
محمد
انقطع كنت تتحدث عن اعتقال 10 من قوات
الدعم السريع
انتقال عدد يقارب العشره
اين بالضبط محمد
اين بالضبط محمد جرى اعتقال عشره عناصر من
الدعم السريع
نعم منطقه حيه الحلفايه شمال جسم الحلفايه
طيب
اجمالا محمد هل ترى ان الوضع او يعني
الهدنه يعني في ضوء هذه الاختراقات او
الخروقات يعني
وطبعا الاشتباكات المستمره هل تعتقد انه
هناك
من الممكن تمديد الهدنه 72 ساعه كما اعلنت
الدعم السريع
كل غدة يتم الاعلان لها يتم الالتزام بها
مبدئيا في بدايه فتره الليل ولكن بعد ان
نتجاوز منتصف الليل وعند غالبا عند
الواحده او الثانيه فجر اليوم الثاني
يتفاجا الناس في فروقات لهذه الهدنه الكل
يتهم الطرف الاخر بانه قد قام
باجهاض هذه
الغده خصوصا والسؤال محمد لماذا في كل
الهدن نحن يعني على مشارفنا سادسه الان
لماذا كانت تجري هذه الخروقات يعني هل هي
عناصر غير متقيده غير
منضبطه دعنا نقول لا تحترم الاوامر ام
يعني
ما التفسير تفسير هذه الخروقات لهذه الهدى
يتحدث الجيش بان هذه القوات يقصد قوات
الدعم السريع لعلها فقط الاتصال والسيطره
ما بين بعضها البعض ربما
هذا تفسير ايضا لبعض المحللين
الاستراتيجيين يتحدثون محمود بان بعض هذه
القوات تطلق النار على بعض مواقع القوات
المسلحه المتواجده في اماكن مختلفه ربما
يتحدثون بان هذه القوات لا علم لها بان
هناك غده اصلا من الاساس لذلك تحدث بعض
الخروقات وبعض الاشكالات وسرعان ما ترد
قوات الجيش لذلك تكون الهدنه معرضه
للانتشار نعم طيب الوضع الانساني والمعيشي
كيف هو يعني ونحن في الاسبوع ندخل اسبوعا
ثالثا اذا من هذه المواجهات المسلحه بين
الجيش والدعم السريع محمد
نعم كما ذكرت قبل قليل
تحدث
لولايه الخرطوم يقود بطبيعه الحال مجموعه
من المختصين في مجال سياره المياه
والكهرباء على مستوى ولايه الخرطوم بدات
عمليه الاصلاح لكثير من محطات المياه التي
خرجت خارج الخدمه محطه بحري الرئيسيه التي
كانت ايضا محتله من قبل قوات الدعم السريع
علمنا من السيد والي ولايه الخرطوم بانهم
يقودون حمله شاهدت قبل اكثر من ثلاثه او
اربعه ساعات
قبل عمليه التمشيط شاهدت سيارات الكهرباء
تجوب احياء الحلفايه والكدر
والدروس لاصلاح بعض الاعطاب وهذا دليل
وافي على ان هذه المجموعات المجموعات
الصيانه التي تحدث عنها والي ولايه
الخرطوم بدات بالفعل النزول للميدان وبدا
تباشر عملها في ظل هذه الظروف التي
يصفونها بانها صعب اشكرك شكرا جزيلا محمد
اسحاق عثمان الصحفي السوداني كنت معنا من
الخرطوم بحري
هذا هو امتد القتال الدائر في العاصمه
السودانيه الى اقليم دارفور المطرب غربي
البلاد حيث شهد اشتباكات متقاطعه بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع عدا عن
الفراغ الامي الكبير الامر الذي يثير
المخاوف من اندلاع حرب اهليه
العسكريه والدائر في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم ومحيطها صراعا اخر عمره عقدان في
الغرب البعيد من البلاد منطقه دارفور
دارفور الواقعه في اقصى الغرب السوداني
تحظى بولاياتها الخمس باهميه استراتيجيه
كبيره لطرفي الصراع المتحاربين في السودان
فالاقليم يتشارك حدوديا مع اربع دول من
الغرب تشاد وليبيا ومن الجنوب افريقيا
الوسطى وجنوب السودان تسكن المنطقه قبائل
عده عربيه وافريقيه وسط وفره في الثروه
الزراعيه والحيوانيه والمعادن منذ اندلاع
القتال بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع منتصف ابريل تفاوت حجم العنف في
انحاء دارفور حيث تعرضت نيالا جنوب دارفور
والفاشر في الشمال لقتال عنيف في الايام
الاولى من الصراع لينحسر القتال فيهما
تدريجيا في الايام الاخيره ولينتقل بشده
وعنف الى مدينه الجنينه متسببا بمقتل ما
لا يقل عن 100 مدني وفق الامم المتحده
ومنظمات الاغاثه ونجد الاهتمام الدولي
يتركز اليوم على دارفور التي شهدت نزاعات
قبليه قديمه ومتكرره حيث يظهر فراغ امني
كبير يخشى مراقبون من ان يؤدي الى حرب
اهليه
خاصه مع تزايد التسليح بين المدنيين
وافراد القبائل المتناحره عدا عن اعمال
النهب والتدمير واضرام الحرائق في المنازل
والمباني الحكوميه هذا فضلا عن مخاوف من
ان تلجا قوات الدعم السريع الى الاحتماء
في حاضنتها هناك اذا تازمت الامور في باقي
الولايات لتشتعل الامور اكثر في الاقليم
كل هذه تطورات دفعت الالاف من السكان
المحليين الى الفرار الى تشاد المجاوره
والى جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى بكل متاعهم
فيما يبدو وكانه رحيل بلا عوده
ملوك الشيخ العربيه
قبل ذلك استقبل وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان المبعوث الخاص لرئيس
مجلس السياده الانتقالي السوداني السفير
دفع الله الحاج علي وجرى خلال اللقاء بحثه
الاوضاع الراهنه في السودان واكد وزير
الخارجيه السعودي على دعوه الرياض للتهدئه
وتغليف المصلحه الوطنيه ووقف اشكال
التصعيد العسكري كافه بما يحافظ على
مقدراته ومكتسبات السودان وشعبه
من جهته الامين العام لمجلس التعاون
الخليجي جاسم بن محمد البديوي لتغليف
مصلحه السودان الوطنيه وذلك خلال لقائه
المبعوث الخاص لرئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي بالسودان دفع الله الحاج علي
كما دعى امين مجلس التعاون الى التهدئه
ووقف كل اشكال التصعيد في السودان مؤكدا
الحرص على امن السوداني وسلامته واستقراره
وتماسك الدوله السودانيه ومؤسساتها وشدد
البداوي على مسانده مجلس التعاون الخليجي
للسودان لمواجهه كافه التحديات وتحقيق
التطلعات شعبه
اك
د الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي ضروره عدم
التدخل الخارجي في الازمه السودانيه كما
اكد السيسي في مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع رئيس
الوزراء الياباني
على ضروره الوقف الفوري والدائم لاطلاق
النار في السودان
تلت التطورات في السودان جانبا مهما من
المباحثات حيث اكدت لدوله رئيس الوزراء
الرؤيه المصريه القائمه على ضروره الوقف
الفوري والدائم والشامه لاطلاق النار في
السودان وميت امتناع اي طرف خارجي عن
التدخل في الازمه باعتبارها شانا سودانيا
خالصا بما يسهل من نزع فتيل الازمه ويحود
دون تفاقمها
اذا مشاهدينا نتابع معكم هذه الاخبار
العاجله الان عن البنك السوداني المركزي
طبعا في ظل اجواء السرقه والنهب والمشاهد
التي انتشرت على السوشيال ميديا لسرقه بعض
فروع البنوك في السودان في ظل الاقتتال
الدائر بنك السودان المركزي يؤكد ان
عمليات النهب والسرقه لبعض الفروع للبنوك
في السودان لا تؤثر على ودائع المودعين
بنك السودان المركزي يؤكد ان اموال
المودعين بالجهاز المصرفي امنه في السودان
طبعا اذا عمليات النهب او السرقه في بعض
الفروع اذا لا تؤكد على الودائع يعود
ويؤكد اذا البنك المركزي السوداني ح ذرنا
المنتخبز العمليه السياسيه في السودان
خالد عمر يوسف على حسابه في تويتر حذر من
انتشار المواجهات العرقيه في البلاد في ظل
احتدام الاقتتال بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع مشددا على ان استمرار الحرب سيضعف
الدوره المدني تلقائيا ويتحول لدور هامشي
مشيرا الى ان الموقف المدني الديمقراطي
يجب ان يكون بالضغط لوقف الحرب وتكوين
جبهه المدنيه ديمقراطيه واسعه مطالبا بجيش
واحد يتم الوصول اليه بالاتفاق على خطه
شامله للاصلاح الامني والعسكري تتضمن
تنفيذ الترتيبات الامنيه المنصوص عليها في
اتفاق جوبا للسلام وتمجد الدعم السريع في
القوات المسلحه
وكان المبعوث الامريكي الخاص سابق الى
القرن الافريقي جفريتمان حذر في لقاء مع
صحيفه الجاردن من اطاله امد الصراع في
السودان لانه سيفتح الباب امام جهات
خارجيه تدعم جنرالا على حساب اخر
الصراع في السودان الى منحا اخر وربما
ينتهي بتدخل خارجي لنصره احد جنرال النزاع
ما ينذر بحرب اهليه طويله الامد تقول
صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه
الصحيفه نقلت عن الدبلوماسي الامريكي
ومبعوثها الخاص السابق الى القرن الافريقي
جافري
انه كلما طال امد الصراع سيسمح لجهات
خارجيه خبيثه بدعم جنرال على حساب اخر
رجل امريكا السابق للقرن الافريقي اكد على
ان الساحه متاحه امام القوات الخارجيه في
اشاره الى مجموعه فاغنر الروسيه ولذلك
يتوجب وقف الاقتتال في اسرع وقت ممكن
لتقويد التحرك الخارجي تحذيرات لم تاتي من
فراغ على ما يبدو بعد ان كشف القائد
السابق لفاينر مرات جابيدول للجار
موجوده في السودان منذ نهايه العام
مؤكدا ان هناك 200 عنصر من الوحده
الهجوميه الاولى داخل الاراضي السودانيه
حيث كانت مكلفه بتدريب قوات الدعم السريع
والشرطه المحليه
التحذيرات جاءت ايضا من الداخل على لسان
قائد جيش عبد الفتاح البرهان الذي كشف عن
وجود مرتزقه داخل السودان قدمت من دول
تشاد
وافريقيا الوسطى والنيجر
رئيس الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد الله
حمدوك حذره هو الاخر من امكانيه اندلاع
حرب اهليه في السودان ستشكل كابوسا قاطما
على البلاد والعالم
محاسن حداره العربيه
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس حزب الامه السودانيه مبارك
الفاضل المهدي للعربيه ان قوات الدعم
السريع اقتحمت منزله وسرقته واتلفت عددا
من الوثائق
دخلوا البيت
وكسروا البيت وكما كانوا يبحثوا ايضا عن
وسائق لانهم بعثروا كثير من الوثائق ليس
فقط انهم كسروا الخزن واخذوا ذهب السيدات
وغيره لكن كانوا يبحثوا عن في كان ينظر في
الوثائق
الخاصه بي
فافرعوا كثير من هذه الوثائق
ورموها على الارض بشكل يعني واضح
المهدي قال ايضا ان الحل السياسي في
السودان صعب كونه كون هناك تمردا عسكريا
على الجيش
شوف الان الوضع
لن يكون هناك في حل سياسي لانه هذا تمرد
عسكري والقوات المسلحه قرارها هي ان تنهي
هذا التمرد عسكريا او يستسلم الذين ما
زالوا في الخرطوم لانه معسكرات الدعم
السريع في كل السودان استسلمت في 16 ولايه
الان واستلمت يعني اسلحتها
قرار القوات المسلحه الان
قبلوا وساطه الايات ولكن في اطار ان هذه
الوسائط ستنظر في
استيعاب ما تبقى من الدعم السريع في
القوات المسلحه
اهلا مساء الخير ومرحبا بكم اهلا
الحل
الحل الامثل يبدا بوقف اطلاق النار
واختلاف ما بين طرفين يمثلان
القوات المسلحه السودانيه
وقوات الدعم السريع وهم كلهم نحن ننظر لهم
كابناء السودان
والاختلاف تحول الى تعبير عسكري
ولذلك لا يمكن ان ننظر في اي اوجه خلاف
قبل ان يتم وقف اطلاق النار بين الطرفين
ثم استعاده الحياه الطبيعيه
للمواطنين في كافه المدن ثم هل ترون هذا
واردا ممكنا استاذ امام ام هذه تبقى في
اطار التمنيات فقط
لا والدا لا وارد لا يمكن ان تكون في
اداره تمنيات نحن كقوه سياسيه نعتقد انه
مهم جدا الان
انه القوه المدنيه يعني صوتها
وتعبر عن الموقف الوطني للشعب السوداني
بضروره الانتقال الى حياه مدنيه كامله في
اداره الشؤون البلاد
ينبغي ان يكون الصوت المدني اعلى من الصوت
العسكري الان الان الصوت العسكري
وقرار
الطرفين بحل الخلاف عبر العنف مرفوض مرفوض
تماما ولا يمكن ان يتم اي اي طرف لا يمكن
ان يتوصل الى اهدافه بهذه الطريقه نحن
الان في الاسبوع الثالث وانت تراك ما قلت
المشهد الان الماساوي الذي صحيح في
المواطنه السوداني العالي اذا نعم
عليهم ان يستعيدوا دور دورهم
هل يمكن للقوى المدنيه بالفعل ان تلعب دور
الوسيط بين البرهان وحمتي لانه منذ بدايه
الاقتتال يعني في يومه الاول جرى التواصل
مع مع الطرفين ولكن ليس لم يكن هناك يعني
اي استجابه يعني كان هناك يعني حتى خارجيا
لكن هناك اقتتال مستمر المحللون يرون بانه
الرجلين لن يجلس الى طاوله الحوار الا اذا
انتصر احدهما على الاخر عسكريا
وحقيقه اخي العزيز
المشهد كان منذ
انتصار ثوره
ديسمبر المجيده كان مختلف
وكان تقريبا
القوه المدنيه السياسيه لم تكن في موقع
متقدم من اداره شؤون البلاد نقير بذلك
وانه كان المشهد يدار بالمكونه العسكري
ولذلك قد يكون فعلا الان
القاده العسكريين لا يلقوا بالا الى
الخيار المدني انه مجلس للطرفين وقعوا على
الاتفاق الايطالي الذي
يحدد ضروره عوده الجيش الى مهام الاساسيه
والخروج من السياسه هذا الان الاتفاق
الايطمان هل ترونه ما زال على قيد الحياه
بعد كل الذي حصل
طبعا الاحداث انا في اعتقادي الاحداث
تجاوزت هذا الاتفاق الايطالي اصلا كان ما
بين المكون العسكري والمكون المدني صحيح
هو الذي وقعت عليه وهي قوه سياسيه في اطار
العمليه السياسيه والعمليه السياسيه اصلا
كانت تهدف الى انهاء الانقلاب العسكري
اللي حدث في 25 اكتوبر وتحول الحياه الى
السلطه المدنيه الكامله الان الان بعد
115 ابريل اعتقد انه نحن في حوجه ماسه الى
نقل جديده في اطار العمل السياسي المدني
بحيث انه يكون هو
اللي يبيس اداره يدير المشهد السياسي في
السودان
ومعالجه الاختلافات العسكريه الان للحوار
السياسي الذي يستطيع فعلا ان يع هذه
القضايا سواء كانت الخلافات ما بين
المؤسسه العسكريه او الخلافات ما بين
القوه السياسيه نفسها في اطار التحول
المدني الديمقراطي وهذا ما نجعله نحن في
حزب الامه في توحيد الرؤى في كيفيه الان
انتقال الى مهام التحول الديمقراطي المدني
الكامل ونتجاوز هذه
العمليه السياسيه برومتها لانه
انتهت باحداث 15 ابريل ولا مكان هنالك
الان الى وجود سياسي للمنظومه العسكريه
برمتها وهذا ايضا اخي العزيز يعني يتطرق
لنا مهم جدا ان الحديث عن الحركات المسلحه
الموقعه على اتفاق السلامه الان ضروره ان
تحدد موقف واضح جدا في المرحله القادمه
بالعمل السياسي البحث وهذه كلها قضايا نحن
نعمل عليها الان ولكن الان المهمه
الاساسيه هو كيفيه وقف اطلاق النار
والتحول الى معالجه الحاله الانسانيه
التي نعاني منها في كل المدن السودان شكرا
جزيلا لك من الخرطوم رئيس لجنه السياسات
في حزب الامه القوميه امام الحلو
اكدت الشرطه السودانيه ان قوات الاحتياطيه
المركزي فصيل تابع لها وقد تم الدفع به
الى الشوارع لتامين الاسواق وممتلكات
المواطنين وشددت على ان من يقودها هم
خريجو كليه الشرطه والقانون وقالت الشرطه
ردا على الدعم السريع في البيان انه لا
وجود للامن الشعبي في قوات الاحتياطيه
المركزي مؤكده بان مقر البنك المركزي
الرئيسي لم يتعرض لاي هجوم وانا الحريق
الذي تم الاعلان عنه يعود لاحد فروع البنك
القتال
مخاوف من ان يؤدي الصراع الى حرب طويله
الامد
صراع انفجر منتصف ابريل ولم يهدا بعد
طرف صراعي الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع
قرر المواجهه بالسلاح وتبادل الاتهامات
اعلاميا
حصيله كبيره من القتلى والجرحى
الاف الفرينه الى دول الجوار وعمليات
اجلاء كبيره ومستمره
واستظروف انسانيه صعبه
هدنه معلنه وجهود دوليه لوقف القتال
لكن اعمده الدخان لم تغب عن سماء الخرطوم
حاليا نحن في المنطقه بتاعت المرسى
المواطنين والسكان في المنطقه
المجاوره من هنا مباشره من النيل شيرو
مويه بدعم شرب شيلوها من النيل ومن هنا من
المرسى وانت ماشي
شديد جدعاني
تتحرك بيه من المناطق الصهينيه
وهنا والمنطقه خطيره شديد يعني
[موسيقى]
اعلنت اللجنه الدوليه لصليب الاحمر عن
ارسالها لاول شحنه مساعدات انسانيه من
العاصمه الاردنيه عمان الى بورسودان وقالت
اللجنه في بياننا ان شحنه المرسله مؤلفه
من ثمانيه اطنان من المعدات الجراحيه لدعم
مستشفيات السودان ومتطوعي جمعيه الهلال
الاحمر السوداني بالاضافه الى مواد تخدير
وادوات تضميض ولوازم خياطه الجروح وغيرها
من المعدات الجراحيه التي يمكن ان تستخدم
لعلاج الاف الاشخاص الذين اصيبوا بجروح
جراء الاشتباكات في السودان
هذه الشحنه الاولى من المساعدات الحيويه
ونعمل ان تصل شحنات اخرى ونتمنى ان تستمر
هذه المساعدات اما فيما يخص من يستلم
المساعدات فهي تذهب الى المستشفيات
والهلال الاحمر السوداني والصليب الاحمر
يتواصل مع الطرفين لكي يحصل على الضمانات
الامنيه اللازمه ولكي تتمكن فرقنا من
التحرك بامان وتصل الى اماكن متضرره
كمستشفيات الخرطوم
تحول المنظمات التطوعيه في السودان تعويض
التوقف التام للمستشفيات المتخصصه في
الولاده حيث تقدم الخدمات الصحيه لعدد من
الحوامل في ظل شبه الانهيار للنظام الصحي
السوداني وقدر صندوق الامم المتحده للسكان
عدد النساء الحوامل في الخرطوم
220 الف حامل معرضات للخطر لعدم تلقهن
الرعايه الطبيه اللاسمه
سيد حامد في الخرطوم 24 الف من هنا على
الاسابيع المقبله حسب تقديرات صندوق
المتحده لسكان 60 مستشفى هو الان خارج عن
الخدمه من ضمنهم مستشفى الولاده اكبر
مستشفيات الولاده في السودان الامر الذي
دعا منظمه ميد جلوبال لتمويل تشغيل مستشفى
الندى عن طريق منظمه سابا
والمستشفى حاليا بيقدم خدمات الولاده
الطبيعيه والقيصريه بصوره مجانيه بالكامل
بالاضافه الى خدمات الرعايه الصحيه
للاطفال
وزادت المخاوف من كارثه كبيره في توفير
الدواء في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم مع
دخول الاشتباكات بين قوات الجيش والدعم
السريع اسبوعها الثالث
صيدليات مغلقه ورفوف ادويه شبه فارغه هذه
حصيله نحو اسبوعين من الاشتباكات يضاف لها
عمليه نهب واسعه طالت صيدليات ومخازن
ادويه في العاصمه السودانيه هنا في مدينه
ام درمان يستمر اغلاق عدد كبير من
الصيدليات منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات في ظل
تحذيرات من تفاقم الازمه الصحيه على مستوى
البلاد علينا الادويه
الخلاصه اللي عندنا تماما او على وشك
ادويه الضغط وادويه السكري
والادويه بتشتغل على الجهاز العصبي او
الادويه التاثير العصبي
خصوصا مرضى الصرع
ديل الناس طبعا اساسا عندهم مشكله في
الحايل الادويه دي اساسا ما متوفر في
الظروف العاديه فيها شح والان المشكله بقت
اكبر تهدد الازمه الحاليه صحه الكبار
والصغار على حد سواء فاسعار الادويه
بارتفاع مستمر فيما اصنافها المتوفره
بانخفاض مقلق وجد الاحداث الدوحه
بنسلين
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن او لذاته
صيدليه ما لقينا ما خلينا حته ما لقينا
وحتى عربيه عشان يجيبوا لي الدواء ما في
بنزين ما في هناك طريقه نمرق من البلد
عشان نمشي نفتش الدواء نجيبه اما بالنسبه
للمستشفيات فلا يزال القليل منها الذي
يعمل في الخرطوم يعاني نقصا حادا في
الادويه والمستلزمات العلاجيه الاخرى خاصه
المتعلقه
بالجرحى والمحاليل الوريديه ما يفاقم من
معاناه المرضى مع استمرار توقف الامداد
الدوائي الحكومي نور الحصني العربيه
قال المتحدث باسم اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه
الاطباء في السودان الدكتور سيد محمد عبد
الله قال للعربيه ان عدد الوفيات الحاليه
في السودان بلغ 425 وفاه وذلك وسط
المدنيين فقط مشيرا الى ان اعداد الوفيات
قد يكونوا ضعف ذلك العدد واضافها سيد محمد
في لقائه مع العربيه ان عدد الاصابات بلغ
الفين واحد وتسعين اصابه مؤكدا ان الكثير
من المصابين لم يستطيعوا الحصول على
المساعده لحد الان بلغ بلغت الوفيات
425 وفاه وسط المدنيين كما تعلمون هذه
التقارير تصلنا فقط من المستشفيات قد يكون
تكون الاعداد اضعاف لان لا تشمل العسكريين
ولا تشمل الذين لم يتمكنوا من الوصول لهذه
المستشفيات والمراكز عدد الاصابات بلغ
2091 وسط المدنيين اؤكد انه وسط المدنيين
كثير من هذه الاصابات لم تستطيع الوصول
لعدم وجود الممرات الامنه ولان عربات
الازعاف سته منها تم قصفها وحتى
البقيه لم تستطيع المرور لنقلها هؤلاء
الجرحى ونقل الامدادات الطبيه
كيف كنتم بتشتغلوا كيف كيف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رصدت كاميرا العربيه وصولها سفينتين
عسكريتين تتبعان للجيش الامريكي
والبريطاني رصدت وصولهما الى ميناء
بورسودان لاجلاء رعاياها ورعايا دول اخرى
وصل الان قبل قليل هذه القطعه
العسكريه البحريه الضخمه التي تتبع للجيش
الامريكي وصلت قبل قليل الى ميناء
بورسودان هذه القطعه التي تتبع للبحريه
الامريكيه ستعمل على نقل نحو 300 من رعايه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايضا سفينه
تتبع الجيش البريطاني هذه السفينه ايضا
رست قبل قليل في ميناء بورسودان هذه
السفينه مزوده بطائره حربيه هليكوبتر الى
جانب ايضا وجود للجيش البريطاني الذي جاء
بمعيه هذه القطعه البحريه ستعمل ايضا كما
علمنا على نقل رعايه بريطانيين وعدد من
دول اوروبا وعدد من الدول العربيه وممثلين
لبعثات الدبلوماسيه
ايضا رصد مراسل العربيه نزار البجداوي
احوال العالقين الذين ينتظرون الخروج من
البلاد نتابع نحو اليوم العاشر تمضي
عمليات الاجلاء لرعايه دول العربيه
والاجنبيه والاسيويه من شرق السودان الى
عدد من الدول في المنطقه اكثر من نحو عشره
الاف من رعايه الدول الاجنبيه تم اجلائهم
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه عبر ميناء
بورتسودان وما يقدر لاكثر من سته الاف
غادروا عبر مطار بورسودان الدولي الى
وجهات دوليه مختلفه ومع استمرار عمليات
الاجلاء الا ان مئات من الاسر السوريه
واليمنيه ما تزال حتى اليوم في انتظار
استكمال اجراءات مغادرتها للبلاد احنا مو
طالبين اكثر
من اي بلد يقعدوا في الناس او يستضيفوهم
شكرا احنا بس بدنا ممر امن من هنا الى
الحدود السوريه وشكرا
البعض فضل البقاء داخل مركز التسجيل
والحصر هنا واخرون عملت السلطات المحليه
على توفير دور مؤقته لاوائهم في ظل ظروف
يحاول الجهد الرسمي والشعبي بمدينه
بورسودان تخفيف وطاتها على العائلات
والنساء والاطفال الموجودين حاليا بشرق
السودان نزار البغداوي لقناتي العربيه
والحدث مدينه بورسودان شرقيه السودان
اعلنت الخارجيه البريطانيه عن رحله اجراء
اضافيه غدا من ميناء بورتسودان وقالت
الخارجيه ان رحلات الاجلاء الجويه السابقه
اجلت حتى الان او اجلت عفوا حتى الان ما
يبلغ
2122 شخصا فيما تستمر عمليات نقل الرعايه
الى يوم غد
اعلنت القنصليه الروسيه في جده ان
السعوديه اجلت عشرات المواطنين الروس على
متن سفن حربيه من السودان وكشفت القنصليه
الروسيه انه في الوقت الحالي وصل نحو
اربعين روسيا ومعظمهم غادروا الى روسيا
والبعض الاخر الى دول اخرى
[موسيقى]
فرع عشرات الالاف من اللاجئين عبر الحدود
من السودان الى تشاد المجاوره هربا من
النزاع المستمر
[موسيقى]
كذلك فر عشرات الالاف من اللاجئين عبر
الحدود من السودان الى تشاد المجاوره اذا
كما تابعنا نتابع المزيد من الصور البيوت
في جسم بتاعت شورتا قعدنا محل الجسم طوال
الليله حرب جاي انتم قال لهم دقيت لعيال
التلفون قلت له
مشينا قدر وحليت مشي
اذا تاخرنا في التحرك الان سيفوت الاوان
فصل الامطار يقترب وسيحل خلال اسابيع
قليله ان لم نقدم المساعده للناس ستغلق
الطرقات وسيبقى اللاجئون عالقين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات